hi everyone I milano ishara Lana's odd
and I just wrapped up my first day of
games com so I'm here in Cologne in
Germany after 20 hours of being on a
plane which was exhausting i'm still
really tired but i thought the first
game that i would talk to you guys about
is sunset overdrive and that's actually
just because when i tweeted about it and
posted on Facebook that's what everyone
asks for the most so the first thing you
notice about sunset overdrive is that
it's very insomniac the last game that
insomniac made was fuse and if you still
had really cool weapons but it just
wasn't as creative a game kind of felt
more gritty than anything sunset
overdrive is the complete opposite of
that it really bright nique splodey and
it's it's very over-the-top it's an open
world game where basically people had
this energy drink that turned them into
mutants and I actually tried the energy
drink not mutated yet but it tasted like
V and it was actually really nice so I
can understand why everyone drank it but
basically you play as a person who did
not drink the energy drink and decides
to mess all the mutants so and what I
played there's a lot of grabbing on
walls and you can kind of grind on
railings which is really familiar it
feels like an old Tony hope game but the
actual wall traversing is really really
cool you can jump on things that almost
aren't there you don't have to look for
that out of place brick kind of thing
and it seems like you just flip over the
side of any building you want and it's
really seamless but also really well
integrated with the combat if you don't
run away and jump all over everything
you're probably going to die as soon as
you get cornered by an elf mutants you
don't really stand a chance of getting
out so you need to utilize the
environment around you and some of the
things in the environment can actually
hurt enemies as well without you even
realizing there was one thing that I
jumped on that when it happened it like
released other things that would
distract the mutants I didn't know that
we just happened then was activated and
I was like well that was convenient
apparently instance that I would drive
you do also get to have full character
customization where you can you know
change pretty much everything about the
way you look but I didn't get to
experience that I was just playing as
one kind of generic dude but I feel like
having character customization
this game would be really cool because
it's a really fun really fast-paced
really action-packed kind of ridiculous
game that doesn't suit having a set in
stone character it doesn't need that you
can't apparently also customize your
weapons as well you can have one weapon
customization and a bunch of amps and
apparently these can do things like turn
you into a file when you dodge or create
a storm or make flames while you're
grinding on the rail I guess it's like a
mod or a perk but they call it an amp
which really suits the tone of sunset
overdrive you also have a style mirror
and sunset overdrive and to keep your
style meter up you basically need to
like leap and grind and rack up as many
combos as you possibly can and the game
is quite tall if it doesn't want you to
stay in one place and you know hack away
at enemies it really wants you to jump
around the environment and that's how
you get those style points it kind of
does feel like one of the more
ridiculous tony hawk games like maybe
Tony Hawk American wasteland but crossed
with a third-person shooter it's bizarre
but it works so well so that is sunset
overdrive I have it so many more games
to bring you guys coverage of so many
more hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video I am going to sleep so hard the
jetlag is so real